welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and whoa we just got a new trailer
for the black widow movie which has been
pushed back again and again and again
and now it's coming out july 9th they're
gonna do a dual release in theaters but
also on disney plus premiere access
so everyone will be able to see it i'm
so excited i've waited too long for this
movie and i'm glad they have a new
trailer to remind us all of what this
movie is gonna be so i'm gonna react to
it and
talk about maybe some big takeaways from
it here we
go
no we don't unless you have
old stuff civil war but that was in an
age of ultron
oh yeah
oh fade to white
who is that
that's um okay
oh okay cool
[Music]
there's a lot of new stuff in this oh
half and half
taskmaster in drakov i think
kablooie
i'm so excited to see what this scene is
what is going on
i'm done being in marvel movies what
is this
[Music]
oh i love it oh
chills
okay
nice nice okay uh i am once again
excited to have this movie in my life
remember marvel movies guys
okay so just some reminders of what this
is gonna be we know this story is gonna
be set between captain america civil war
and infinity war and we also know from
trailer footage that it is revisiting
the city of budapest
we know the city has some significance
to hawkeye and black widow it's where
they worked on a past mission and they
brought it up again and again and now
we're finally hopefully gonna see what
that whole budapest story was
and early on in this trailer we get some
images from past avengers movies we see
something from the first avengers film
when they suit up and before the battle
of new york
interesting they include this one shot
from the airport battle in civil war but
it was from the
trailer for civil war before spider-man
was added
into that team iron man lineup so they
didn't use it from the movie they used
it from the trailer
interesting more shots from the battle
sokovia
something that's very important right
now on the falcon the winter soldier the
opening sokovian hydra base raid from
age of ultron
that hydra bases was revisited in one
division and then he has some shots from
the time heist
and end game including when she let go
of clint on vermeer sacrificing herself
so that he could get the soul stone now
interestingly mixed in here is this
flashback shot from her age of ultron
scarlet witch nightmare that she was
given
where she was firing at this target in
the red room
but what they don't show in this trailer
is what she thought was the target was
actually a victim with a cloth bag over
his head she was kind of being
brainwashed into this heartless assassin
and in this black widow movie it's those
memories that she is now
wading back into as painful as that
might be so the big question from this
trailer is who is this blue-haired kid
i assume this is natasha romanov when
she was a younger girl she dyed her hair
blue but you can see those red roots
i thought this was the case but yeah
this actress is mila jovovich's daughter
her name is ever anderson
so apparently we're gonna be seeing some
flashbacks to when natasha was kind of
brought into the whole red room process
as a young girl
we also see flashback footage of young
natasha with like a younger david harbor
a younger rachel weiss making it seem
like they actually could be her real
parental figures who were willing to
give her away to the red room
and she has always felt resentful of
that so yeah this might be confirmed
that alexis shostakov red guardian
was either her father or maybe just a
father figure that she lived with part
of a unit that she was part of
her original family that was willing to
part ways with her and that was some
resentment that she's always carried
since
yeah because you see him saying these
girls are the toughest girls in the
world and i think
natasha and elena must been raised as
sister figures they're not actual
sisters
so this is kind of a foster family that
came together before it was broken apart
to
serve the russian state now other big
new stuff from this trailer we see a bit
more of taskmaster
specifically how taskmaster is connected
to ray winstone's character whom we
haven't seen yet but he does show up
here
and i'm pretty sure he's gonna be
playing drakov you remember the name
drakov back in the first avengers film
loki taunted natasha saying don't you
remember the hospital fire in sao paulo
drakov's daughter there's some drakov
and his daughter back in natasha's past
some fellow red room black widow
assassin whom natasha just let
die actually olga kurlienko is going to
be playing some limited role in the
series she may be playing drakov's
daughter either way we see ray winston's
character in this kind of russian
office room that i pointed out in past
trailer breakdowns with this red
global layout it looks like there is one
asset in morocco
maybe is that casablanca looks like
there's gonna be some other african
setting here i assume this is where he
deploys all of his different black widow
agents just to see where all of them are
at any one time but yeah
this guy seems to also be controlling
taskmaster he says bring her home
yeah we get this other cryptic shot of
the taskmaster helmet and garb as like
it looks like a woman's arms
uncover it now a lot of people have
speculated that rachel vice's character
melina shostakov aka iron maiden
could be the identity of taskmaster or
maybe elena belova
i don't think so maybe one of them
shares this identity
with someone else but i think a better
candidate would be otf ben lay's
character rick mason who has not shown
up in
any promo footage whatsoever so he seems
to be kind of like a tech support
asset to natasha but yeah i think that's
gonna be him behind the mask he's the
one who's been studying the adventures
learning all their moves copying a lot
of their gear
and we close out with this glorious
russian female choir
singing the avengers theme that's so
freaking cool i
had serious chills hearing that and
imagine these are just the agonized
cries of the women of the kgb red room
who have seen themselves as avengers
their whole lives but are now scattered
and abandoned and trying to avoid
thinking about all the ink on their
ledger
hey by the way i am wearing our falcon
winter soldier inspired anarchy
assembled custom design shirt that you
can get at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow new rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
you love
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]